SEAN HANNITY IN NEW YORK CITY.
>> Sean: WELCOME TO "HANNITY."
BREAKING NEWS NIGHT.
"HANNITY" WATCH ON THE EXTREME
RADICAL LEFT.
IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE BEGIN.
YOU ASK YOURSELF SOME QUESTIONS.
DO YOU WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO
HAVE MORE CONTROL OR LESS?
TAKE MORE OF YOUR HARD EARNED
MONEY OR LESS?
DO YOU WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO BE
MORE INVOLVED IN YOUR BUSINESS
OR LESS?
DO YOU WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO
HAVE TOTAL CONTROL OF YOUR
HEALTHCARE OR LESS?
DO YOU BELIEVE THE GOVERNMENT
HAS A DUTY TO PROTECT YOUR
BORDERS AND HEROIN, FENTANYL,
HUMAN TRAFFICS AND GANGS AND THE
CRIMINAL ELEMENT?
NOT THE PEOPLE THAT WANT A
BETTER LIFE.
NOW IT'S PERFECTLY CLEAR, THE
LINES HAVE BEEN DRAWN.
EVERY SINGLE ELECTED DEMOCRAT
ALMOST ALL OF THOSE RUNNING TO
CHALLENGE PRESIDENT TRUMP IN
2020, THEY WANT MORE AND MORE
TOTAL CONTROL OF YOUR LIFE.
THEY DON'T TRUST YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
REMEMBER THEY THINK WE ARE
IRREDEEMABLE, THAT WE CLING TO
GOD, GUNS, BIBLE AND RELIGION
AND WE ARE THE SMELLY WAL-MART
PEOPLE.
THEY WANT CONTROL OF EVERYTHING.
IT'S BEYOND RADICAL.
IT'S SCARY.
IT'S A FAILED IDEALOGY TRIED
OVER AND OVER.
IT CREATES DEPENDENCY.
THEY MAKE PROMISES THAT NEVER
COME CLOSE TO WHAT THEY PROMISE.
THE PEOPLE PROMISING ALL OF THIS
GREAT STUFF, THEY REALLY ONLY
WANT POWER FOR THEMSELVES.
SOCIALIST CONGRESSMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ AND FAR LEFT
SENATOR ED MARKEY WILL SET THEIR
NEW GREEN LEGISLATION.
TELL DICTATE HOW YOU HEAT YOUR
HOME AND COMMUTE TO WORK.
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ WANTS
THIS COUNTRY -- WE JUST BECAME
THE NUMBER 1 PRODUCER OF OIL ON
THE PLANET SURPASSING SAUDI
ARABIA AND RUSSIA.
ALL FOSSILE FUELS, WE DON'T HAVE
THEM IN 10 YEARS.
SHE WANTS TO NATIONALIZE
ENORMOUS, PROFITABLE PRIVATE
INDUSTRY.
KILL IT OFF COMPLETELY.
ALL OF THE MILLIONS OF HIGH
PAYING CAREER JOBS IN OIL AND
GASES AND ENERGY SECTOR.
GONE.
IT WILL FORCE EVERY AMERICAN TO
PAY DRASTICALLY MORE EXPENSIVE
FOR ALL FORMS OF ENERGY.
THE LIFEBLOOD OF OUR ECONOMY.
ACCORDING TO ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ IF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOESN'T TAKE DRAMATIC
ACTION, THE WORLD WILL END IN 12
YEARS.
THAT ONLY GIVES US 2 YEARS OF
HER PLAN.
HE THINKS THE FUTURE OF HUMANITY
IS AT RISK BECAUSE OF ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE.
WE HAVE MORE ENERGY.
WE CAN HELP ALLIES CREATE
MILLIONS OF HIGH PAYING JOBS FOR
AMERICANS.
WE TRIED YOUR WAY.
IT DOESN'T WORK.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I DON'T THINK THAT FOR THE
FUTURE OF HUMANITY AND FOR OUR
COUNTRY TO CONTINUE TO PROSPER
WE CAN'T HAVE ANOTHER PRESIDENT
CYCLE WHERE CLIMATE CHANGE IS
NOT TALKED ABOUT AT EVERY
DEBATE.
>> Sean: LOOK AT VENEZUELA.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF ENERGY BUT
THEY DON'T HAVE ANY MONEY OR
FOOD.
POVERTY IS RAMPANT.
CUBA.
THEY DIDN'T DO WELL.
FORMER SOVIET UNION.
COMMUNIST CHINA?
LOOK AT LIFE IN ANY COUNTRY THAT
NATIONALIZES PRIVATE INDUSTRY
AND IMPOSES STRICT GOVERNMENT
CONTROLS OVER PRIVATE
BUSINESSES.
THAT'S NOT STOPPING DEMOCRATIC
HOPEFULS LIKE ELIZABETH WARREN
FOR DECLARING THAT CAPTITALISM
CAN BE GOOD ONLY IF SHE AND HER
FELLOW DEMOCRATS HAVE A CHANCE
TO IMPOSE MORE RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> LET'S BE REALLY CLEAR.
CAPITALISM WITHOUT RULES IS
THEFT.
ENCOURAGING COMPANIES TO BUILD
THEIR BUSINESS MODELS ON
CHEATING PAPAL.
-- PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT COMPETITION IN THE
MARKETPLACE.
THAT'S NOT PRODUCING CONSUMER
SURPLUS.
I BELIEVE THAT CAPITALISM WITH
SERIOUS RULES.
THAT MEANS RULES WHERE EVERYBODY
GETS A CHANCE TO PLAY.
>> Sean: EXCUSE ME, A LOT OF
PEOPLE RISK MONEY TO START
BUSINESSES.
NO HOPE TO SUCCEED.
THEY CREATE GOODS AND SERVICES
THAT PEOPLE WANT AND NEED.
THEY EITHER BUY IT OR THEY
DON'T.
THAT'S CREATED A STANDARD OF
LIVING THAT IS THE ENVY OF THE
WORLD.
UNIMAGINABLE IN MOST PLACES ON
THIS EARTH.
WARREN IS PROPOSING A BRAND NEW
WEALTH TAX.
IF YOU MANAGE TO SAVE ANY MONEY
AFTER YOU PAY YOUR FEDERAL AND
STATE INCOME TAXES AND SOCIAL
SECURITY TAX AND PROPERTY TAX,
SENATOR WARREN WANTS TO COME
BACK AND TAKE MORE.
THAT WOULD BE A GOVERNMENT
LICENSE TO STEAL, SENATOR.
BY THE WAY, THEN WHEN YOU DIE,
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WANTS
HALF OF WHAT YOU SAVED.
YOU PAY TO DIE IN AMERICA.
STATES LIKE NEW YORK TAKE 10% OF
WHAT YOU HAVE LEFT.
WHY ARE PEOPLE LEAVING NEW YORK,
NEW JERSEY, AND CALIFORNIA?
HUNDREDS EVER THOUSANDS.
STATESES WITH NO OR LOW STATE
ECONOMIC TAX LIKE FLORIDA AND
TEXAS, 400,000 NEW RESIDENTS
LAST YEAR ALONE.
THE GOVERNMENT WILL NEED VASTS
AMOUNT OF MONEY.
LOOK AT HARRIS'S MEDICARE FOR
ALL PROPOSAL.
3.2-TRILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
10 YEARS.
OPEN YOUR WALLETS AND WATCH OUT.
SOCIALISTS ARE COMING.
THAT PROPOSAL WOULD KICK 177
MILLION AMERICANS OFF THEIR
PRIVATE HEALTHCARE PLANS AND
KILL OFF ANOTHER PRIVATE
INDUSTRY.
WORK FOR AN INSURANCE COMPANY?
BYE.
HARRIS WANTS YOU GONE.
JOBLESS AND OUT OF WORK?
DOESN'T CARE.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN MEDICARE FOR
ALL FAILS LIKE OBAMACARE?
WHAT THEN.
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO SELL BIG
GOVERNMENT PROGRAMS.
THEY ARE THE MOST COMPASSIONATE.
DON'T BE FOOLED.
A GOVERNMENT POWER GRAB PLAIN
AND SIMPLE.
THEY DON'T TRUST YOU.
THEY WANT THE GOVERNMENT TO
CONTROL EVERY ASPECT OF YOUR
LIFE.
THEY WANT TO USE YOUR MONEY.
IT'S ABOUT BUYING VOTES, BRIBE
PEOPLE TO VOTE FOR THEM AND GET
POWER.
THE MODERN-DAY DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
CONTROL YOUR HEALTHCARE,
BUSINESSES AND MONEY.
PRESIDENT TRUMP PUT OUT A GREAT
TWEET TODAY.
DEMOCRATS ARE THE PARTY OF
LATE-TERM ABORTIONS, HIGH TAXES
AND CRIME.
THE DISTURBING STORY FROM
VIRGINIA FROM LAST NIGHT WHICH
WOULD MAKE INFANTICIDE LEGAL.
IT WOULD ALLOW A HEALTHY BABY TO
BE TERMINATED EVEN WHEN THE
BIRTH PROCESS STARTED.
A DEMOCRATIC GOVERNOR SUPPORTED
THE BILL THEN TOOK IT A STEP
FURTHER.
SAYING A BABY'S LIFE WOULD ONLY
BE SAVED OUTSIDE OF THE WOMB IF
THE FAMILY WANTED IT.
THE INFANT WOULD BE RESUSCITATED
WHILE THE BABY IS ALIVE, VIABLE.
LIVING.
SERIOUSLY?
AFTER FACING SERIOUS BACK LASH,
THE GREAT GOVERNOR OF VIRGINIA
DOUBLED DOWN ON STUPID AND EVEN
PLAYED THE VICTIM CARD.
WE WILL SHOW YOU THOSE
DISGUSTING COMMENTS COMING UP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WORKING HARD.
DOESN'T GET THE CREDIT TO
PRESERVE THE RIGHTS AND
PRINCIPLES FOR ALL AMERICANS
INCLUDING NEWLY BORN CHILDREN.
DEMOCRATS ARE SEETHING WITH
ANGER OVER THE PRESIDENT'S
NOMINATION OF ORIGINAL JUSTICES.
I TOLD YOU.
I KNEW THIS MAN FOR OVER 2
DECADES.
HE WOULD GOVERN AS A
CONSERVATIVE.
I HAVE BEEN PROVEN RIGHT AND I
TOLD YOU SAW.
OBAMA WAS A RIGID, RADICAL
PERSON WHOSE POLICIES WOULD
FAIL.
THEY DID.
NOW PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
FULFILLING THOSE PROMISES.
WE SEE THE ECONOMIC NUMBERS AND
SEE MORE PEACE AROUND THE WORLD.
WE SEE HIM CHECKING OFF THE LIST
OF WHAT HE SAID HE WOULD DO AND
APPOINTING STRONG, QUALIFIED
JUSTICES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL KEEP HIS
COMMITMENT.
FOR THOSE OF YOU WHO DOUBT, HE
WILL GET THE MONEY FOR THE WALL.
HE ANNOUNCED TODAY HE IS SENDING
MORE TROOPS DOWN TO THE BORDER
AS THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
NEW MIGRANTS IN MULTIPALE
CARAVANS ARE MARCHING TO OUR
BORDER WITH UPWARD OF 12,000
PEOPLE.
WHAT IF THEY GET TO A POINT IN
OUR BORDER WHERE THERE IS NO
SECURE WALL OR ENTRY POINT?
WHAT WILL THE BORDER PATROL DO
TO STOP 12,000 PEOPLE IN THEY
RUSHED ACROSS AT ONCE?
NO WALL TO STOP THEM.
I SAID THAT WALL WILL PROTECT
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE
WALL.
UNFORTUNATELY TAKE A LITTLE MORE
TIME TO VET PEOPLE.
THE COSTS ARE OUT OF CONTROL.
IT'S NOT JUST THE RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MIGRANT
CARAVANS.
THE MOST RECENT WEEK.
TWO DEPORTED SEX OFFENDERS
APPREHENDED TRYING TO ENTER THE
UNITED STATES IN TEXAS.
AND A VIOLENT MS-13 GANG MEMBER
WAS CAUGHT.
ALSO ON MONDAY AGENTS ARRESTED A
MAN CONVICTED OF CHILD
MOLESTATION AND THEY GOT HIM
TOO.
TODAY BORDER PROTECTION
ANNOUNCED THE SINGLE LARGEST
FENTANYL BUST IN HISTORY.
THEY CAPTURED OVER 250 POUND OF
THIS DEADLY OPIOID INSIDE A LOAD
OF MEXICAN PRODUCE HEADED TO
ARIZONA.
JUST A STARK REMINDER OF HOW
MANY DEADLY DRUGS COME ACROSS
THAT SOUTHERN BORDER.
DESTROYING AMERICAN LIVES
ESPECIALLY FENTANYL USED BY DRUG
DEALERS TO PUT IN TO HEROIN.
LOOK AT THE NUMBERS.
2016 FENTANYL RESPONSIBLE FOR
46% OF ALL OPIOID RELATED
DEATHS.
IT'S A KEY REASON FOR THE 42,000
PEOPLE DYING FROM OVERDOSES OF
FENTANYL IN 2016.
AN INCREASE OF 10,000 OVER THE
PREVIOUS YEARS.
FENTANYL DEATHS HAVE INCREASED
SINCE 2010 MUCH COMING FROM
CHINA AND SMUGGLED THROUGH THE
SOUTHERN BORDER.
ENOUGH TO KILL ALL OF THE
RESIDENTS OF FLORIDA,
PENNSYLVANIA, UTAH AND PICK
ANOTHER STATE.
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE COULD BE
KILLED.
THAT'S WHY THE PRESIDENT IS
PRESSING THE PRESIDENT OF CHINA
AND HE IS GETTING RESULTS.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ONE THING WE DISCUSSED IN
ARGENTINA WAS FENTANYL.
THIS IS NOT A TRADE DEAL.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT THEY
WOULD CRIMINALIZE FENTANYL
BECAUSE FENTANYL IS KILLING A
LOT OF OUR GREAT AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Sean: BORDER SECURITY IS
ABOUT STOPPING THESE EVIL
CARTELS AND THE FLOW OF DRUGS
INTO THE COUNTRY.
IT'S ABOUT LIFE-AND-DEATH AND
SAVING THE LIVES OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
HUNDREDS DYING EVERY WEEK FROM
HEROIN AND FENTANYL.
IT'S ABOUT STOPPING HUMAN
TRAFFICICKING AND PROTECTING
PEOPLE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE WALL
WITH A DOOR.
CREATING A SAFE, SECURE SYSTEM
FOR IMMIGRATION.
WE GET TO VET EVERYONE COMING IN
AND MAKE SURE THEY ARE CAPABLE
OF TAKING CARE OF THEMSELVES.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO PLAY CHEAP
POLITICAL GAMES RATHER THAN
ADDRESS A LIFE-AND-DEATH AND
SAFETY AND SECURITY CRISIS.
NANCY PELOSI SAID AGAIN TODAY
THAT FUNDING FOR A WALL IS A
NON-STARTER.
SHE OFFERED A DOLLAR SO FAR.
>> THERE WON'T BE ANY WALL MONEY
IN THE LEGISLATION.
TWO THINGS, COST BENEFIT
ANALYSIS.
WHAT IS THE BEST WAY?
WHAT DO YOU GET FOR YOUR DOLLAR
TO PROTECT THE BORDER?
>> Sean: WHAT IS NANCY PELOSI
AND THE DEMOCRATS STANDING FOR
ANYWAY?
WE HAVE DONE THE NUMBERS AND RUN
THEM MANY TIMES ON THIS SHOW.
WHY DID DEMOCRATIC LEADERS
INSIST ON OBSTRUCTING THE
PRESIDENT'S EFFORT TO KEEP
AMERICANS SAFE?
I THOUGHT THEY CARED ABOUT DACA
AND THE DREAMERS AND WHEN OBAMA
WAS PRESIDENT THEY WANTED TO PAY
FOR A WALL.
WHY DO THEY INSIST ON STOPPING
THE RANK-AND-FILE MEMBERS FOR
COMING TO REAL SOLUTIONS AND
NEGOTIATING IN GOOD FAITH?
ONLY BECAUSE THEY ARE CONSUMED
BY ANTI-TRUMP HATRED EVERY
SECOND, MINUTE AND HOUR OF EVERY
DAY.
JUST DESTROY HIM.
THEY HATE HIM MORE.
THAT PUTS YOUR COMMUNITY AT
RISK.
YOUR FRIENDS AT RISK.
YOUR FAMILY AT RISK.
SELLING OUT DREAMERS AND DACA
THAT'S ALL THEY CARED ABOUT.
ANOTHER UPDATE FROM THE
"HANNITY" WATCH ON THE DEEP
STATE.
THE HATE TRUMP MEDIA CAUGHT
REPORTING ANOTHER COLLUSION HOAX
TODAY.
REMEMBER WHEN EVERY MEDIA OUTLET
SPECULATED DONALD TRUMP JUNIOR
CALLED HIS FATHER WITH A BLOCKED
PHONE NUMBER AHEAD OF HIS
MEETING WITH THE RUSSIANS WHEN
THEY TALKED ABOUT IMMIGRATION
AND ADOPTION?